this is how much plaque grows on your
teeth after
not brushing them for a single day
now this is just one day of not brushing
your teeth but
what would happen if you decided to stop
brushing
forever how much bacteria
lives inside your mouth how could this
affect your overall health and
how long could you last before your
teeth fell out
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you stopped brushing your teeth
plaque is a sticky film made up of
bacteria
leftover food particles and saliva
it helps other types of bacteria adhere
to your teeth
meaning it only helps your mouth get
dirtier and
dirtier so we know plaque can grow
pretty quickly on your teeth in just one
day but
what would happen if you stopped
brushing your teeth
for the rest of your life before we get
to that
what lives inside your mouth on an
average day
over 6 million bacteria from 700
different species live
inside your mouth now not all of those
are bad for you in fact a lot of them
promote good health
but some bacteria living in your mouth
are harmful to you
that's why you brush your teeth since it
helps get rid of that harmful bacteria
and now you've suddenly decided to stop
brushing
a week has gone by and you're starting
to notice
some serious bad breath people stay
a little bit further away from you when
you try to talk to them
but bad breath would be the last thing
on your mind
after just a week of not brushing your
teeth
the plaque in your mouth would begin to
harden and form tartar
this is like a really hard plaque that
discolors your teeth
and at this point only a dentist would
be able to get rid of it
and on top of all that your enamel would
begin to be damaged as
bacteria continue to multiply in your
mouth
okay that's one week of not brushing
let's
fast forward to one month in this crazy
experiment
so here's some good news if you normally
spend an
average of four minutes a day brushing
your teeth at this point
you've saved two whole hours hey that's
enough to watch a movie
and then we have some bad news which is
everything else
[Music]
after not brushing your teeth for a
month you'd start to get
cavities these holes in your teeth would
continue to get deeper
and deeper and they'd eventually fill
with
pus
[Music]
as time goes by the cavities in your
teeth would get
worse and worse you'd also start to
develop
gingivitis which would inflame the gums
around your teeth
now good luck trying to eat anything
because at this point
your gums would be incredibly sensitive
this would continue for about a year and
after that
you not brushing your teeth would lead
to periodontitis
this is when the inner layer of your
gums starts to pull away from your teeth
and
form pockets which would collect food
and bacteria
now with all this extra bacteria in your
mouth
your immune system would start to
destroy your gums
and after your gums start to go away
you'd
lose your teeth as they decayed and fell
out of your mouth
and now that you don't have any teeth
you could start to have
health issues outside your mouth a study
in california
found that people who didn't brush their
teeth daily
had a 20 to 65 percent greater chance
of getting dementia than those who
brushed multiple times a day
and for all the guys out there who
decide to stop brushing their teeth
well that could lead to erectile
dysfunction
in a 2012 study it was found that 53
percent of the patients with
erectile dysfunction also had severe
periodontitis
so not brushing your teeth forever would
not only affect your mouth but
other parts of your body as well
my advice just press your teeth it only
takes a couple of minutes a day and
you'll be a healthier person for it
okay so it's obvious that not brushing
your teeth would be
pretty awful for your body another thing
that would be terrible for you
only drinking coca-cola
but we'll leave that story for another
what if